we start with some exclusive polling for
this program that shows the extent of
disruption
faced by firms in the uk because of the
new post-brexit trading relationship
with the eu well the polling by yougov
freen king live shows 52 percent of
companies say they face disruption since
the beginning of the year
due to the new trade agreement 13
percent of those say they experienced a
large amount of disruption
17 say disruption has been moderate
while 22 percent
reported a small amount of disturbance
but when you ask companies that do a
moderate or large amount of eu trade
this rises to an overall figure of 80
percent of companies
that have faced disruption with more
than a quarter saying that they have
faced a large amount
of disruption we're joining me now to
talk about this the independent business
trade expert ali renison
and sally jones brexit lead at ey
welcome to you both uh sally let me
start with you are you surprised by
these figures
no i'm not at all surprised ian that's
very much the kind of information that
we've been hearing coming from
our clients and our contacts and uh ali
same question to you does this correlate
with what you've been hearing on the
ground
certainly i think in terms of those who
trade with the eu we're seeing a
significant disruption and you have to
remember that in january you know it was
really a perfect storm of variables
covered and only a few days for
businesses to get to grips with the new
arrangements
uh remember that uh the trade figures
for january showed a 40
drop in exports to the use so that
tallies fairly consistently
ally what i'm slightly baffled by is
that in the run-up to the end of the
transition period i mean we had lots of
businesses on this program
and time and again i would say to them
are you ready for brexit are you
prepared for it
and they all said as prepared as we can
be well clearly
something went to miss with that
planning or otherwise it's proved to be
uh
worse than they expected i think there's
a couple of different variables you have
to look at and at the end of the day we
knew that we were going to be outside of
the customs union
an eu customs union in a single market
but the level of detail the guidance
that you know businesses needed to
actually get to grips with
only came in about some six seven days
before the actual uh new arrangements
took place and i think that's why
you've seen a real sort of scramble um
not only just from british businesses
but also the customers and suppliers in
europe to be actually ready to be able
to deal with
um the the fine detail of what that
change was going to mean in practice so
it was a pretty perfect storm at the end
of the year
sally you were noting an agreement there
i mean during january we heard from
ministers that these were just teething
troubles
is that your sense or is it uh deep
rooted than that
no it's it's deeper rooted than that ian
without a doubt uh when we talk to our
businesses our clients
there are teething problems without a
doubt so for example
it's taking them about 10 times longer
to complete the at border paperwork that
they need to move goods across boilers
but they're getting better at it they're
getting more practiced and that time is
starting to come down
but i would guess at least half of the
businesses that we talk to tell us
that they have permanent structural
problems
that are not just teething problems
which are going to fundamentally change
the way they do business in the future
and do you think do you worry sally that
this eventually might lead some
businesses just say well this is just
not worth the candle we're going to uh
put put our attention elsewhere
yes i think some businesses will do that
so to give you an illustrative
real-life example william shatner of
star trek fame
has a little online star trek
memorabilia business and he says he's
that the uk is the one
country that he won't keep selling to
because it's now too difficult
now you may not want a star check
memorabilia
phaser or tribble but it's indicative of
the fact that things are much much
harder for small businesses in
particular to get ready to trade into
the uk than they were
pre-brexit ali what's striking from our
polling is that uh
the problems such as they are largely
affect bigger companies rather than smes
yeah and i think that to some extent um
you know when you look at the variables
that larger businesses have to contend
with
a lot more different sort of trade
linkages into different parts of europe
um there's a much different sort of
stream of issues that they have to
contend with
you know smaller businesses i think are
actually facing as much trouble when
they deal with sort of
individual sort of single issues but the
larger business grows the more whether
it comes from immigration changes trade
and services changes trading goods
customs disruption there's a lot bigger
set of things to have to contend with
presumably ali things are going to get
worse rather than better because at the
moment the uk government of course has
just uh
extended for another six months the
grace period
for uh checks coming into this country
presumably when that happens things may
get even harder
yeah i think that a lot of people are uh
looking at the export side of things
when in fact from an import side the uk
governments delay the kind of controls
that we now see for
trade going into europe and so i think
when the full brunt of that hits you
know that's the government i think is
right to do that to try and extend the
areas that it can control
um but you know a lot of businesses who
export also import
um and so when you actually get the full
effect of that all these sort of delayed
grace periods are going to add up
um that the hope is is that because
you've staggered some of that impact it
won't be as significant
so sally what on earth are you telling
clients at the moment
take a deep breath uh wait for the dust
to settle
get through and then once you've got a
clearer idea of which are your teething
problems and which are the structural
ones
then it's time to act um i'm really glad
that ali mentioned services businesses
because they are more disrupted even
than goods businesses in our experience
goods businesses just in inverted commas
have additional costs to manage and
that's hard enough but services
businesses
anyone who's dealing with behind border
barriers they can have absolute
prohibitions for me
being able to trade and i think that's
going to be the big story coming out in
months to come
and uh separately ali i mean we if you
looked at our polling we also asked a
few questions on the pandemic
it's clear that the pandemic has had the
bigger shorter term impact but most
people think it's going to be fairly
short-lived
yeah i mean it's interesting is that you
know the the hope is and what i think
the government has to
make sure that it tries to avoid as much
as possible is that for even for some
services businesses
a lot of businesses actually went into
lockdown in december and so the full
effect i think
wasn't necessarily felt um as sort of
lockdowns start to unwind both in the uk
and europe
uh you have to try and make sure as far
as possible the uk is not actually at a
competitive disadvantage that when
lockdown is actually lifted as you
mentioned potentially short-term impact
um that the uk's left the british
businesses aren't at a competitive
disadvantages in terms of being able to
open up and trade with their nearest
neighbors
all right ally we'll have to leave it
there really appreciate you joining me
this early in the morning where you are
sally great to see you too as always
thank you thank you